2016 was an incredible year for movies
so many great films made us laugh cheer
and scream here are our top movies of
2016 number 10 is mawana it's easy to be
cynical about yet another disney
princess movie but when there is
well-executed as the excellent mawana is
then all that snark easily washes away
the film is a visual standout just look
at these water effects but outside of
the technical spirit also delivers in
all the ways every great disney movie
should it's full of heart full of laughs
and it's got some outstandingly catchy
songs that you'll be humming for months
every path i make every road leads back
to the place i know if I can go along
and while mallanna's tale of living her
dreams while at the same time fulfilling
her responsibilities as a leader
resonated strongly with us special
mention must go out to the
hardest-working man in show business the
most charismatic bag of muscle on the
planet the rock also known as Dwayne
Johnson Johnson is outstanding as a
demigod Maui and who knew he could sing
what can I say
you're welcome for the ties to Sun the
sky at number nine is the witch an
unnerving horror film that will haunt
your thoughts for days after watching it
the film centers around a pilgrim family
banished from their new england
settlement and forced to start a new
life in a remote area on the edge of a
terrifying and ominous forest just as
they settle into their new environment
the family's youngest child a newborn is
abducted
oh this isn't a film about a monster
that steals a baby what follows is a
series of Horrors much worse goats
producing blood when milked possessed
children and that's only what's in the
trailer writer director Robert eggers
creates an immersive world in his debut
film that feels unsettling and shrouded
by the forces of evil 8th on our list is
green room the movie follows punk band
the eight rights as they tour the
country with no budget when the band
plays at a skinhead bar discovers a
murder in the green room they become
hostages backstage Patrick Stewart plays
the neo-nazi owner of the club who is
really good at covering his own tracks
at any crimes that happen there the late
Anton Yelchin delivers an amazing
performance as a musician who has to try
to step up and save his bandmates lives
what's surprising about green room is
that it takes a huge tonal turn that the
audience doesn't see coming even if they
know the plot while it is in a horror
film it does more for the genre than any
other movie this year writer-director
Jeremy Sonnier delivers a brilliantly
intense thriller that has some real
cringe-worthy violent scenes it does
have some gory moments much like the saw
or hostile series however green room has
much more well-rounded characters and a
cohesive plot coming seventh on our list
Ryan Gosling and Russell Crowe star as
the nice guys a duo who are either the
world's best or worse detectives we're
leaning towards the latter this comedic
trip through 1970s la works mostly
because of the undeniable presents from
and the chemistry between its two stars
you're in the pool yeah why I had to
question the mermaids what were you
doing while I was working writer
director Shane Black create some
extraordinary circumstances for them the
unlikely pair is forced to work together
to solve a case where nothing is quite
what it seems to be its lethal weapon
with a whole lot more sleeves in
slapstick and it totally worked for us
rough Deadpool owns the six spot on this
list for a number of reasons it
revolutionized the stale comic book
genre and also made us completely forget
about this travesty
Wade Wilson is a medical experiment gone
wrong and a comic book movie experiment
done right it broke all the comic book
movie cliches to share the story of an
explicit foul mouth antihero it's an
action-packed visual stunner laugh out
loud funny and a hell of a good time oh
I'm touching myself tonight number five
is kubo and the two strings in an age
where cg effects can render the visually
impossible into a mundane reality the
craftsmanship and patience that a
stop-motion film like kubo requires is
absolutely mind-blowing you never want
to take your eyes away from the screen
here and as kubo himself says in the
film if he must blink do it now but
forget about the outstanding technical
achievement that is kubo kubo and the
two strings made it onto our list of
best films of the year because of its
wonderful heartfelt story which is at
once a grand fable and also a deeply
personal film about family and
relationships kubo is the best type of
family film a grand adventure a rousing
tale all ring from a place of emotional
truth at number 4 is Captain America
Civil War comic book fans have seen
heroes fighting other heroes time and
time again it's only natural we'd see
the same happen on the big screen in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe after seeing
the Avengers team up to fight incredible
odds there now fighting for screen time
as the foundation of the team begins to
crumble Civil War re-examined the way
the Marvel heroes can operate instead of
following the same formula that worked a
dozen times Marvel Studios tried
something different even with the movie
crammed full of superheroes they managed
to introduce some more not that I'm not
ah yeah I'm not number three is 10
Cloverfield Lane the original 2008
Cloverfield was a found-footage monster
movie the story followed six characters
making their way across New York City 10
Cloverfield Lane takes a completely
different approach with only three cast
members and a third person POV the
majority of the movie happens in the
confines of a bomb shelter the tension
was only amped up by having John Goodman
thrusting his hips while dancing in
front of a jukebox easter shower the
suit is an awkward moments at the dinner
table at a time where movie trailers act
as a concise summary of the entire movie
10 Cloverfield Lane managed to contain
plenty of suspense and twists to catch
the audience's off guard the less you
know about the plot and the constrictive
environment makes this a movie that will
keep you on the edge of your seat just
make sure you're not seated next to
someone that's ready to smash a bottle
over your head number two is rogue one a
movie set in the Star Wars universe
seems like a no-brainer when the movie
focuses on a cast of brand new
characters it's a whole new ballgame
apart from moving away from the familiar
heroes we've grown to love the film
shifts the tone we might expect by
showing more realistic aspects of an
intergalactic war we've seen nameless
rebel trooper shot down and paid little
attention to it our cast here is on a
mission against massive odds and doesn't
have the luxury of giant wiki's or fancy
lightsabers to save their butts there's
a nice mix of old and new Star Wars
elements we have to see new planets
characters and ships set within a
familiar time period the filmmakers have
shown that there are other areas the
Star Wars mythos that can be explored
outside the saga movies the tone is a
little darker than you might expect but
there is also plenty of humor and hope
rebellions of built home hope and coming
in at number one arrival this wasn't
even debated the film was amazing and
this was the best-looking seen in any
film this year
Amy Adams is mixture of fear and
interest when she first sets eyes on the
aliens was exactly how we would have
felt in the same situation the only
difference is we would have seen our
hazmat suits apart from amazing acting
and beautiful visuals this film has an
effect on the way you see the world
after watching it as the story
progresses it changes our understanding
of the concepts of time language and
handshakes that's a proper introduction
and those are top movies of 2016 for
more movie nerdiness plus TV and comics
stick with gamespot universe and if you
want to stay up to date with all of our
movie videos be sure to subscribe to
gamespot universe on YouTube it's
gamespot's permanent home for TV movies
and comics as of January third subscribe
now so you never miss a video